صور متداوله ايضا كذلك بث اعلام تركي من
منطقه تقسيم في اسطنبول حتى الان هذه هي
الصور التي توفرت
سنحاول الحصول على مزيد من التفاصيل مع
مراسل العربيه في همم اسطنبول هذه صور
ايضا اخرى متداوله كذلك لهذا الشارع ربما
الذي وقعت في هذه العمليه الانتحاريه نعم
الاعلام التركي الان يتحدث عن 11 جريحا في
انفجار بمنطقه تقسيم في همم اسطنبول همم
كذلك همم ربما عن ضحايا في هذه همم
العمليه
الانتحاريه طبعا الاعلام بعض الاعلام
المحليه التركيه تحدث عن الانفجار في همم
اسطنبول في منطقه تقسيم همم لم يؤكد حتى
هذه اللحظه ان كان عملا انتحاريا او عملا
همم ارهابيا لكن الاعلام التركي مؤكد الان
همم جرح 11 شخصا في هذا الانفجار بمنطقه
همم تقسيم وصفوه كذلك بانه انفجار ضخم
انفجار كبير في هذه المنطقه منطقه همم
تقسيم التي تم اغلاقها في همم اسطنبول بعد
انفجار اسفر عن احد عشر مصابا حتى الان لا
تاكدات حول همم موضوع همم الضحايا او ان
كانت هناك همم ان كان هناك قد لقد سقطوا
في هذه العمليه وفي هذا التفجير الذي
وصفته همم بعض الصحف وسائل الاعلام
التركيه بانه انفجار ضخم وانفجار ايضا
كبير على ان تغلق منطقه تقسيم في اسطنبول
كما نشاهد ايضا في هذه الصور المتداوله
والاكتئاب طبعا في هذا الشارع بعد هذه
العمليه التي همم لم يؤكد الاعلام التركي
بانها بعمليه انتحاريه او عمليه ارهابيه
اكتبها بالقول انفجار في اسطنبول دون اا
بالتاكيد كما ذكرنا
هذه صور اوليه وتابعها واياكم على شاشه
العربيه تبعت